yes do not adjust your screens in the
past week I have done more videos with
blue backgrounds and red backgrounds
blue backgrounds being when I just
talked about in movie news and whatnot
red backgrounds being reviews but hey
let's chalk up one more blue background
because at the beginning of some IMAX
versions of The Hobbit and unexpected
journey they're showing the first nine
minutes of Star Trek into darkness and I
sign so we're gonna talk about it with a
blue background so the star trek into
darkness prologue starts out on earth I
believe it was London and it shows the
star date which I was like why do they
show the star date unless the star Tate
is relevant could be an homage to The
Captain's Log star date this is that
that I would think they would save that
for Kirk to say it so the fact that they
show the star date I find intriguing and
I start theorizing [ __ ] the point is
there's this family and their little
daughters in a hospital she looks like
she's dying and then the dad steps out
to take a look at the landscape because
apparently the sight of buildings
soothes him and you hear this ominous
voice all I can save and you're like oh
benedict cumberbatch I know that voice
how can you say for Sherlock then it
shows a man it's Cumberbatch and then
the scene ends and we're on this other
planets to plan it from the trailer
where it shows like all these red vines
and plants Kirk and bones are running
the running because they're running from
this civilization and they're doing an
operation this volcano is going to wipe
out this civilization so really
primitive civilization we're talking
Spears and loincloth it's literally not
ready for first contact yet so they're
doing this operational incognito they're
running because Kirk Jack this thing
he's like I don't know what it was they
were just bowing to it which made me go
you're a pretty shitty officer I
understand Kirk's supposed to be a rogue
and whatnot you know he's supposed to go
to the beat of his own drum but what was
the point of him taking this artifact
that they obviously worship as a guy was
it just so they could have a chase
sequence with the civil as a I don't
know when this all was happening out
there okay so we're just gonna do a
standard operation in which case is
gonna reintroduce the crew the
enterprise I wish it was more relevant
but okay but if you do take the time to
notice what could be some really solid
foreshadowing it's actually quite
awesome among them running Spock is in
the volcano and he has this device
that's gonna render the volcano
completely useless so the civilization
doesn't get wiped out which I loved
because when I saw the volcano scene in
the trailer I was like really another
movie that has the climax of the entire
thing take place in a volcano just seem
like a cliche thing for a movies like oh
we need a really honest and threatening
environment for the end of them
moviemaking a volcano but it's not it's
actually at the beginning of the movie
which really calmed my nerves why I try
not to jump to conclusions but sometimes
she can't help it when you see things
like that so bones and Kirk jump off of
that cliff they go underwater they swim
to the enterprise the enterprise is
under this lake that's where it's hiding
from this civilization all right cool
then they get back on the enterprise and
Kirk's like Scotty beam amount Scotty
it's like I can't there's too much
activity we need life sight and thus we
have the moral dilemma in the first nine
minutes of Star Trek into darkness
Kirk's like alright raise the enterprise
let's get him out of there and Spock's
like don't do that the prime directive
states if they cannot see the enterprise
we cannot interfere with them Kirk's
like dude there's got to be an exception
mate it's your life Spock's like no the
needs of the many outweigh the needs of
the few I was like Wrath of Khan
reference which makes me think why that
then again the 2009 Star Trek Spock also
says when you eliminate all
possibilities whatever remains no matter
how improbable must be the truth but she
also said in Star Trek 6 and that Star
Trek has nothing to do with 6 however is
from Sherlock Holmes and Sherlock Holmes
is in this Star Trek and he said
something that was from Sherlock Holmes
and my brain just exploded China
ok back to point then Kirk looks at
bones and he's like if it were me down
there and him up here what would he do
bones is just like he'd let you die so
then it shows Spock just kind of looking
around it shows the lava boiling more
and more and more it looks like Spock
accepts his fate then it goes black the
end I was like cliffhanger in the
prologue really I love a good
cliffhanger though so it's like ok I get
it I'm glad it ended right there because
it keeps me on my toes and I'm like
alright now I really want to see this
movie but a cliffhanger like that I know
Spock's not gonna die one because you
see the enterprise rise from the water
and the trailer so you're like ok well
they obviously leave that way oh I don't
know another way for the enterprise to
leave being under water other than
coming out from the water you also see
Spock in the trailer and a scene that's
not in this prologue so we obviously
gets out of that situation and the point
is Spock lives what a cliffhanger like
that it might as well have just been mr.
Worf fire dad dad dad dad dad
dardo I'm just saying man that was a
cliffhanger and a half however if you
see that situation as foreshadowing for
what's to come in this new Star Trek
movie it's badass
I mean is there gonna be a situation
where Kirk has left somewhere and
Spock's gonna need to make that same
choice and he's maybe going to make the
choice Kirk makes will it show Spock
evolve like that and this may
and it's been revealed that Benedict
Cumberbatch plays a character named John
Harrison what Harrison's story is I
don't know but he seems pretty pissed
off at the Federation so was he formerly
with the Federation was he in a
situation where he had to get out of
deep [ __ ] and the prime directive said I
know just you bye and they left him
there to die did he have to leave
someone to die and that's why he's
pissed at the Federation the fact that
this is even making my brain turn like
that shows that this prologue did its
job well and then when it ends you see
some more stuff that's pretty much from
the trailer that we already saw but it
does show the part from that I believe
it was the Japanese extended trailer
where you hear Cumberbatch say something
like what would you do or how far would
you go to save your family and he shows
his hand and Spock's hand like against
the glass kind of like Wrath of Khan
also although coming back to officially
does not play Khan I can't help but feel
like this is going to feed into Khan's
story somehow also because Alice Eve
plays Carol Marcus and I saw this
interview with her where she was talking
about her character just like you know
Carol Marcus she was in the original and
she was in Wrath of Khan and she paused
before she said Wrath of Khan and
scratched her shoulder and I was like
why did you pause and why did you
scratch your shoulder you looked
uncomfortable like you almost feel like
you revealed too much information was
she not supposed to allude to the Wrath
of Khan so a seemingly routine mission
for the prologue ultimately looks more
monumental than it initially did because
of the foreshadowing and I'm pumped so I
actually put a link below to the
interview with Benedict Cumberbatch and
Alice Eve talking about their roles in
the movie watch Alice Eve's body
language when she mentions Wrath of Khan
I'm telling you she's hiding something
so what do you think about all of this
what are your theories about star trek
into darkness
do you think Alice Eve was hiding
something whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you